Dis grenier, tu veux faire quoi cette
nuit ? La même chose que chaque nuit.
Seb essayer d'emmerder le monde. C'est
joueurs du grenier. Ces joueurs du
grenier testent des jeux pourris et se
vengent la nuit. Leur obsession
profonde, c'est de faire chier tout le
monde. Quel connard ! C'est joueurs du
grenier. Grenier, grenier.
[Musique]
1 2 3 C
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde. Alors oui, je sais, on a
déjà parlé de jeux tiré de dessins
animés. On a fait Tintin et les
Schtroumpfs évidemment he Tasmania et
bip bip. Pugsley pour la famille Adams.
On a aussi fait Cool World mais
finalement quel est le jeu tiré de
dessins animés le plus pourri ? Quelle
est la quintessence de la Rome de merde
? Est-ce qu'on l'a déjà testé ? Et ben
non. Mais avant de commencer cette
vidéo, vous le savez, dans les joueurs
du grenier, on teste plein de jeux
différents pour au final n'en retenir
que quelques-uns. Et cette vidéo a été
particulièrement dure. D'ailleurs,
énormément de jeux ont été joués, très
peu ont été sélectionnés. Voici donc un
hommage au jeux pourris qui nous ont
quitté pendant l'écriture de ce
[Musique]
test. Mais d'abord définissons la valeur
étalon d'un mauvais jeu tiré de dessins
animés avec Mighty Max sur Megga Drive.
Alors vous vous souvenez peut-être des
jouets Mighty Max. Les filles avaient
polycket. Les garçons avaient Mighty
Max. Ça n'avait rien à voir. Et le
maître des tortures qui t'attend. Mighty
Max, attention à l'œil monstrueux. Le
cyclope sera-t-il ta prison ? Mighty Max
? Mighty Max, c'est idéal. Mais [ __ ]
mais qu' viire son araignée là. Elle m'a
bousillé ma prise cette conne.
Bref, outre les jouets, c'était aussi un
dessin animé et c'était un héros trop
cool et branché. Regardez, il lit des
livres et il a une statue de Socrate
dans sa chambre.
Le jeu nous permet donc de choisir entre
Mighty Max, sa copine que je vais
appeler cota féminin dont tout le monde
se fout ou un rou. Et regardez comment
ce jeu vous donne instantanément envie
de
[Musique]
jouer. Bref, on joue donc le rôle de
Max, un espèce de gitan de l'espace qui
doit ramasser des morceaux de métal
dispersés à travers tous les niveaux et
les ramener dans un portail magique.
Évidemment, des merdes à ramasser, il y
en a plein hein. Parce qu'un jour, Satan
s'ennuyait, s'est dit qu'il en avait
marre de faire souffrir les gens avec
des jeux de plateforme et que donc il
allait inventer un nouveau genre, les
jeux de plateforme où tu dois collecter
des objets. C'est génial. C'est la même
chose, sauf qu'en plus tu repasses sans
arrêt au même endroit. C'est comme
frapper un mec dans les couilles pendant
qu'il se noie. Et en plus, Max ayant
décidé d'enculer la gravité he ça donne
à ce jeu une saveur toute particulière.
Mais je veux pas sauter là. Allez,
doucement. Un petit saut, un petit
saut. Un tout petit saut. Juste Ah
[ __ ] de merde. Mais bon, c'est pas
grave. Là, je viens de finir le niveau
1, le niveau du volcan. Alors, c'était
super long et chiant. Mais j'ai super
hâte de découvrir à quoi va ressembler
le deuxième
[Musique]
niveau. On passe ensuite aux pierres à
feu. Alors des jeux Flintstones, il y en
a eu pas mal mais très souvent c'était
des jeux un peu vides comme The Flint
Stones sur Master System. Avant de
commencer, je tiens quand même à saluer
l'effort de la Master Système qui crache
ses poumons pour essayer de sortir une
voix
digitalisée. T'inquiète pas, c'était
bien. Je te jure. En plus, ils sont
trompés parce que normalement, c'est pas
Yabadabadou qu'il faut dire, c'est Youpi
parce que Yabadabadou, ben traduit en
français d'après la boîte, c'est youpi !
Donc le concept du jeu est passionnant.
On doit peindre mur. Alors, on prend la
peinture dans le pot et on la met sur le
mur. Et puis des fois, on doit ramener
la gosse qui s'échappe du berceau et qui
vient gratter notre mur. Et puis s'il y
a un trou sur le mur à la fin du temps
réglementaire et ben tu recommences. Ça
a l'air absolument passionnant comme
jeu.
Voilà, tout va aller mieux. Alors,
autant ce jeu n'est pas terrible, autant
il est pas catastrophique comme son
cousin les Flintston sur DOS. Donc
voilà, le jeu hein. Bon, c'est plutôt
pas mal si seulement c'était sorti en
1975. Enfin, je veux dire sérieusement,
le jeu est sorti 2 ans après Megga Man
2. C'est sorti la même année que Super
Mario World et pour prendre strictement
la même plateforme, c'est sorti la même
année que Prince of Persia. Alors,
pourquoi on dirait que les graphismes
ont été faits par un enfant de 8 ans ?
Quoi ? Ah, je savais qu'il avait menti
sur son CV. Non, mais vous imaginez,
c'est comme si Mass Effect Andromeda
était moins beau que Witcher 3 alors
qu'il est sorti 2 ans plus tard. Ça
n'aurait aucun sens. Donc bref, ce jeu a
plein de problèmes, mais le premier
d'entre tout, c'est je crois avec Dragon
Slair sur NES la pire gestion des sauts
que j'ai jamais vu. On a certes le
système classique du "J'appuie, ça saute
et plus j'appuie longtemps, plus ça
saute haut, mais ça marche sur des jeux
ass rapides comme Mario et surtout sur
des jeux où tu peux sauter en diagonale
parce que là, ce jeu n'a que deux sauts,
le 100 % vertical et le 100 %
horizontal. Et par-dessus ça, tu ne peux
pas lâcher le bouton tant que tu n'es
pas l'altitude requise sans quoi ton
personnage retombe au sol." Écoutez,
regardez, c'est simple. Regardez combien
de temps je dois appuyer pour un simple
saut.
Mais sérieusement, et j'avais moins de
latence dans les années 90 quand je
jouais à Hugo Délire depuis mon
téléphone. Comment je suis censé réussir
à finir un jeu où tu as l'impression de
jouer sur un serveur en Australie et où
tout te tue en un coup ? Alors bon, les
crocodiles à la limite, je peux
comprendre mais [ __ ] les tortues, les
araignées et des fois même tu soulèves
un propre caillou et dessous il y a un
cafard qui te bute en un coup. Merde !
Et pourtant étonnamment ce n'est pas le
jeu tiré de dessins animés le plus
pourri. Le vainqueur d'ailleurs n'est
même pas un jeu de plateforme. On en a
retourné des dizaines et le grand
gagnant est Roger Rabit sur
NES. C'était même pas branché. On trouve
plusieurs jeux Rogé Rabit. Tout d'abord,
on a le Roger Rabit sur Game Boy, un
genre de action RPG qui respecte assez
bien le film. Alors, graphiquement pour
de la Game Boy, c'est carrément
honorable et même s'il y a quelques
passages assez frustrants où tu te fais
tirer comme un
lapin, globalement, c'est plutôt un bon
jeu. Rien à voir avec la version NES
développée par Rare et édité par Oh non
! Oh mon dieu ! Non, vous voyez ce logo
arc-en-ciel ? Et ben ça ça veut dire
qu'on va l'avoir dans le cul. Le jeu
commence par une partie un peu
originale. On a deux boutons. Alors le
bouton B sert à taper et OK, j'avoue,
c'est un petit peu rigolo parce qu'on
peut concentrer son key pour faire un
coup de poid surpuissant. D'ailleurs, on
peut aussi taper au pif les gens au
hasard dans la rue et c'est un petit peu
marrant.
Bah écoutez, nous à l'époque on avait
pas GTA et brûler les voitures c'était
pas encore à la mode. Alors, on se
défoulait comme on pouvait, hein. Ce
moment vous était proposé par réflexion
de droite. Quant au bouton A, lui, il
sert à fouiller les pièces et les
différents objets. OK. Alors, autant je
comprends le principe, mais pourquoi
c'est si lent ? Vous devez fouiller tous
les objets de toutes les pièces, de tous
les immeubles. Et il y a plusieurs
objets dans chaque pièce et plusieurs
pièces dans chaque immeuble et plusieurs
immeubles sur la carte. Et à chaque fois
c'est
sérieusement. Non mais c'est une
table.
Hm. Cette table est vide. D'ailleurs,
c'est même pas que les meubles. Et
visiblement, je vais aussi devoir
fouiller toutes les poubelles de la
ville sans aucun indice. OK, donc là,
j'ai trouvé des arêtes de poisson.
Je suppose. Non, mais sans déconner,
qu'est-ce que c'est ? À quoi ça sert ?
un clochard qu'on contrôle là. Je veux
dire, on rentre chez les gens, on
fouille, on trouve des trucs. Mais ça
sert à quoi ? OK, là j'ai trouvé un
morceau de fromage et alors ? Bonjour,
je vais vous prendre ce morceau de
fromage là, c'est pour mon enquête. Et
puis je vais prendre ce morceau de pain
aussi. Et puis je vais prendre un
couteau aussi en pièce à conviction. Et
puis tant que j'y
suis. Bon, vu que vous êtes en
permanence poursuivi par les yennes,
certains items vont vous servir à vous
défendre, je suppose, comme les bombes
ou les baramines, par exemple. Allez,
vas-y, viens par là.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
utilisation des baramines ? Ne approchez
pas, j'ai un pistolet, je vais m'en
servir.
Je D'ailleurs, au passage, à quoi sert
Roger Rabit ici, hein ? Il fait rien à
part me suivre, il a pas prononcé un
mot. Il n'a absolument aucune utilité ni
aucune influence dans le jeu et il est
même pas introduit vu que le jeu n'a pas
d'introduction. Et d'ailleurs, c'est
quoi le but du jeu ? Parce que bon, j'ai
vu Roger Rabbit mais c'était il y a très
longtemps. J'ai oublié parce que là ça
pourrait aussi bien être les aventures
d'un clochard qui commence à avoir des
hallucinations à force de manger les
trucs qui trouvent dans les poubelles.
Bonjour madame, je suis détective et
voici Roger Rabit, mon fidèle compagnon
de la paix un dessin animé qui
m'accompagne partout.
Vous aurez une poubelle chez vous ?
Bref, donc ben on se balade d'écran en
écran en essayant de ramasser des items
et en espérant que ça active une
quelconque histoire qui lanceraiit le
jeu. Alors bon, je peux bien parler aux
gens certes, mais ils ne servent à rien
parce que là, pouvez-vous m'aider ? Oui,
ce bâtiment est vide. Euh, merci
connard. Enfin, on va dire que le fait
de tourner en rond, ça nous permet de
profiter davantage de grands moments
comme celui-là. Mais [ __ ] mais tu es
pas un ennemi juste à l'écran de
chargement, bande de guignole. Oh
[ __ ] mais je te jure. Mais quoi ?
Mais quoi
? Ça n'est pas
amusant. Il me suit en plus.
[Applaudissements]
Et sérieusement, je dois aller où ? Ça
fait des heures que je fouille les
poubelles de toutes les maisons. J'ai
trouvé la voiture là pour aller plus
vite. J'ai aussi trouvé le club de
Jessie Carabit qui me demande de trouver
son numéro et de l'appeler, chose qui
est impossible dans le jeu d'ailleurs,
vu qu'il n'y a pas de téléphone. En
réalité, sur ce passage et on était
censé faire ce numéro en vrai sur son
vrai téléphone et on tombait alors à
l'époque sur la voix de Jessica Rabit
qui nous donnait des indices pour finir
le jeu. Maintenant le numéro n'existe
plus évidemment mais pour l'anecdote, il
a été remplacé par une hotline qui te
propose des étudiantes chaud et coquin.
Je devrais quand même surveiller à qui
il vendent ce genre de numéro parce que
bon en vrai si avec la mode du rétro
gaming, il y a des gamins qui se mettent
à rejouer au jeu. Allô, c'est Mickey.
Salut mon petit. Tu sais que je porte
pas de pantalon là. Euh c'est Donald
alors. Bon alors après avoir essayé un
petit peu n'importe quoi, j'ai fini par
comprendre qu'il faut donc balancer une
rose au sol pour que Jessie Carabine
descende de son podium et veille bien te
parler. Logique he f rose tout ça. Bon à
la base, j'avais lancé le portefeuille,
ça me semblait plus logique.
Ah ouais ouais. Allez-y, j'assume. Donc,
accrochez-vous. Voilà la soluce. Alors,
Jessica Rabit vous dit d'aller fouiller
une grotte. Dans cette grotte, il faut
utiliser une lampe. Mais je je Mais
[Musique]
mais bref, il faut également avoir les
chaussures à ressort que tu peux acheter
au magasin. Pour que les chaussures
soient disponibles à l'achat au magasin,
il faut rentrer et sortir en boucle de
l'immeuble jusqu'à ce que le bon item
apparaisse. Sachant que le même item
peut revenir plusieurs fois d'affilé.
C'est pas du tout chiant,
chaussures. Allez, mais donne-moi tes
[ __ ] de chaussures. Les chaussures ?
Mais
non, chaussures. Chausses, chaussures,
chas. Vous avez les chaussures ? Et
maintenant, vous avez les chaussures. Et
maintenant, c'est bon, je vais l'acheter
ton [ __ ] d'item. Alors maintenant, tu
me donnes des chaussures. Mais [ __ ]
mais c'est quoi ? C'est un magasin
sifflé cette merde.
Chaussures. Ah ! Ensuite, on utilise les
chaussures pour passer le trou de la
grotte, puis le hocher sur le serpent,
ce qui permettra de ramasser le premier.
Va te faire [ __ ] Va te faire [ __ ]
Et je sais pas pour quelle [ __ ] de
raison votre Sprite glisse vers le bas
quand vous ramassez un objet. Du coup,
ça vous fait tomber dans le trou. Donc
ben faut y aller prudemment, doucement.
Et toute cette opération là, les
vendeurs de merde, les items pourris,
les machins, il faut recommencer ça
quatre fois dans quatre grottes
différentes pour ramasser les quatre
bouts de papier qui te permettent
d'ouvrir la suite du jeu. Quatre fois
tout
[Musique]
ça. Par ailleurs, il faut également
faire attention à ce que Roger Rabit se
fasse pas enlever par un corbeau, sinon
c'est la mort. Ou de pas se faire
écraser, sinon c'est la mort. Ou de pas
tomber sur les yennes, sinon on a droit
à un concours de blague qui mène à la
mort si on répond mal. Concours de
blague. Allez, vas-y, le jeu. Fais-moi
rire. Et ça fait quoi un éléphant quand
il pleut ? Et ça mouille.
[Musique]
Au passage. Alors, est-ce que j'ai
mentionné que l'emplacement des
bâtiments n'est absolument pas indiqué
du tout et que vous n'avez aucune carte
de la ville ? Ouais. Bon, en même temps,
vous avez raison, on s'en branle vu les
autres problèmes du jeu. C'est comme
annoncer un mec paralysé atteint du
cancer qu'il a un rhume. Donc bref,
alors Jessica justement nous donne
l'emplacement des autres grottes et
après avoir recommencé trois fois toute
cette opération, il est temps d'aller à
Tun Town en passant par ce mur là. OK.
Alors, comment on fait ? C'est quoi le
bouton pour passer le mur ? J'ai pas
accès aux items. A B select. Mais
qu'est-ce que je comprends pas
[Musique]
? Mais [ __ ] mais sérieux. Select start
select A select B L1 R2 remettre les
gaz. Mais non, je pensais que je pouvais
passer le mur parce que j'avais l'item
des bombes. Mais il ne faut pas les
bombes, il faut la dynamite ce qui n'a
rien à voir du tout j'amis. Et pour la
dynamite, il faut aller voir
[Musique]
non
mais je vous jure que j'ai essayé toutes
les stratégies vaudou du pif pour
essayer de changer l'item de ce [ __ ]
de magasin. Rentrer et sortir. Rentrer
et aller dans la rue et sortir.
Sélectionner l'item. Parler au vendeurs.
Sortir et faire trois fois le tour du
quartier. Mais c'est même plus des
stratégies que je fais. C'est du
spiritisme et ça change que dalle. Des
fois ça change sans raison et des fois
ça reste pendant des heures. Change,
change. J'ai déjà tout t d'items de
merde. Je veux juste la
dynamite. La
dynamite. Donne-moi la dynamite. Dom de
Dieu. Écoutez, mais c'est pas grave. Je
vais rester devant le magasin et taper
les gens qui passent en attendant que
vous soyez livrés.
[Musique]
Merci.
De rien, mon fils. Une fois la didamite
obtenue, vous pouvez enfin passer le mur
et aller vers le boss de fin du jeu.
S'il vous plaît, un boss simple. S'il
vous plaît, un boss simple. Oui, mais ça
va, je suis pas le père Noël. Je lui ai
tout balancé à la gueule. les baramines,
les brigues, les cigares explosifes, les
bombes, toutes les balles de mon fling
et sa barre de vie a à peine bougé de mm
ou oui oui c'est ça la barre de vie.
Alors en gros, il y a marqué un d'
milieu. Alors ça c'est lui, ça c'est moi
et celui qui se rapproche le plus du
mot, il a perdu. C'est une barre de vie
parfaitement logique. Même si ce jeu
avait été codé par des shadoc, ils
auraient su qu'une barre de vie, ça
ressemble à ça. Alors finalement,
qu'est-ce qui reste quand on a tout
balancé ? les coups de point, on charge
le coup de point à fond, on s'approche
sans se faire toucher, on frappe, on
regarde le demiMimètre de dégâts qu'on a
fait et on recommence l'opération un
million de fois. Et je l'ai pas dit mais
attention, il faut charger la barre de
puissance à fond pour que ça le touche.
Et pour charger la barre et bien il faut
mâcher le bouton, hein. C'est pas juste
genre tu restes appuyé. Ceux qui
reviennent donc à mâcher tout le bouton
pendant toute la durée du combat qui
peut durer environ 30 minutes à
condition de pas perdre avant. Tu peux
pas me faire ça, c'est le boss fit.
Encore une journée bien remplie, Seb, du
moins jusqu'à demain soir. Et pourquoi
renier ? On fera quoi demain soir ? La
même chose que chaque nuit, Seb. tenter
d'emmerder le monde. M
[Musique]